[Music]
what does it take to change the world a
breakthrough idea an unparalleled
background in technology and execution
rich wealthy connections to Stanford
investors over my 10 years of experience
in consulting then start of financing
and high tech in Silicon Valley I've
become convinced that we are profoundly
mistaken in our conventional wisdom and
what it takes to make breakthrough
technology succeed and to truly change
the world
it took me a moment of meeting the
Google X co-founder face to face to
realize that the techniques that
astrophysicists and laser scientists are
using in Silicon Valley's most
innovative laboratories are simple
repeatable steps that anyone with access
to basic supplies can start doing at
home right away
and even more excitingly if we were to
really realize this as a society our
communities companies and classrooms
would never be the same
my journey toward learning more about
innovation began when I was a young girl
in Topeka Kansas when I was young my
greatest hope for the future of
technology would be that we would invent
a better remote control and my greatest
hope for government was that we'd find a
way to keep the streets swept
particularly in the snow while
minimizing taxes for my dad's small
business growing up in Kansas I never
imagined that a non engineer could work
for a company like Google but in 2010 I
found out in fact they could and after a
year of getting my ducks in a row I
applied for Google and I landed my first
job there very quickly into my time at
Google I got the opportunity to help
build tech support teams to help make
Gmail and other Google Apps usable by
business
is large and small around the world we
started off trying to train people from
many cultures how to answer a simple
tech question on the phone and resolve
it so the customer could move on with
their day but over time we started to
realize that this awesome staff we'd
built weren't just tech support agents
in fact they were very skillful very
creative humans who could do a lot more
for the humans on the other side of the
phone than we'd originally thought at
first we started small helping new
customers go from fixing an early
problem to anticipating what might
happen next then if someone called with
one question we try and help figure out
what was actually going on that they
were trying to use technology to solve
and then finally we realized that if we
were really effective at helping our
customers on the phone we could help
them bring technology to bear on their
work force in their company to power
present and future goals that they found
important the most amazing learning for
me in this process was actually the
innovation doesn't have to happen only
for teams that are developing software
in fact when you can teach people to
innovate whose work involves other
people amazing things can happen and
things can transform with this Small's
intervention as one interaction on the
phone after I left Google it wasn't long
before I found myself in a very strange
classroom in an innovation mansion on
the border of Alamo Square in San
Francisco I stepped through the
beautiful entryway looked at the grand
staircase coming down from above and
followed red rope lights into a
mysterious basement that turned out to
be a very curious place indeed here Tom
Chi a co-founder of Google X with
unveiling the methods that Google X's
engineers had used to develop
breakthrough technologies that put in
the internet on floating balloons I was
very excited and I was especially
enthusiastic because the one thing our
team
I figured out how to do was to solve a
bottleneck and an engineering talent
basically how do we get more technical
skills and technical people to help
bring our customer insights into real
opportunities and tools for our
customers it's Tom begin to share he
talked about how a lot of the world's
wealth runs through its largest
companies but companies don't actually
develop all of the technology that they
create and whether they develop it or
not they tend to own the patents for 20
more years what I started to realize is
we couldn't just trust that the world's
big companies would have a handle on the
innovation that we really need to solve
the problems we want to see solved in
our lifetime instead it was going to
take a lot of people working together
really quickly in order to tackle
problems on the scale of climate change
and we were going to need to get started
right away as tom shared the method I
started to become astonished because
what I imagined would be a highly math
intensive engineering specific
discipline really boil down to three
steps that Google X's engineers use over
and over and over to reduce uncertainty
and bring the reality bring the present
in the future into present reality step
one start with ask it step to build
something basic using pretty accessible
kindergarten level supplies and step
three changes you go again and again
they repeated this process and in the
room we use post-its and scissors to do
the same thing start with a skit build
something basic change as you go start
with the skit build something basic
change as you go the more we've repeated
this process the more it started to sink
in it wasn't just my team at Google that
had had everything we needed to move
forward on building technology in our
corporate context but actually the
classrooms I had grown up in in Kansas
had everything we needed then too I was
infuriated
not sure where I got the message that in
order to create the future I needed
access to the best science and
technology labs and teachers who had 20
years of experience in data science but
at this point I started to realize that
if we all truly believed in this
potential a lot could change and a lot
more people could be involved in
directing that change the next phase of
my career was a 3-year stint testing my
hypothesis that this was a basic process
that anybody could learn I taught people
from 50 organizations from the US
Department of Labor to Girl Scouts
at a science and tech camp I taught
corporate entrepreneurial and nonprofit
sector leaders from Norway to Vietnam
and including the American Midwest and
the biggest insight I had from that
journey was a workshop I taught two
undergrads in central Iowa the workshop
began and everyone started and very
quickly as I do I said let's get going
time to build right yay and this young
woman named Chelsea looked up at me and
said I can't do it I can't go forward
and I said why not she looked at me and
said you're asking me to create and no
one's ever even told me I can be
creative that's when I realized that
there are thousands of creators besides
my original self who don't even realize
that we can create and in fact we are
creating all the time but our own lack
of awareness that that's what we're
already up to and it's absolutely us who
can do it holds us back from really
making headway on the things we care
about the most
what I've learned over the course of
this journey is that imagination and
invention aren't hyper specific
technologies that no one can use it's
that actually it's more like imagination
is a muscle it's a process that anybody
can pick up that you can exercise and
develop and by
to sing in this method you can begin to
make real progress on the things you
care about and your community cares
about the most and you can empower your
workforce and your economy to do exactly
the same if we really live like
imagination as a muscle you all could
make a huge difference even in the rest
of this week maybe you would start by
looking around you for people with wild
ideas who really could just grab a piece
of scrap paper and start to draw what
the wireframe interface would look like
rather than applying to another
accelerator or worse yet quitting if
they don't get in you could look around
at the groups the communities and the
workforce is that you are a part of four
places where actually a lot more as
possible than humans just doing routine
activities and if you did you might find
out that the unemployment graph flipped
starts to look like capacity to innovate
and you could put your ear to the ground
for some innovators either likely or
unlikely who might not yet have been
told that in fact they too can be
creative returning to your routine today
I invite you to start this process by
keeping an open mind for maybe a project
that you haven't been able to move
forward yet is there something that you
can just put on a rough sheet of paper
and hand to a friend to test if you did
I think you might discover that you are
far more inventive even very rapidly
than you ever dared to think
[Applause]